[Musique]
nous sommes venus essayer de d'examiner
comment en fête se passe la
transformation de l'essai de la
recherche de l'innovation projet plutôt
industrielle est à cet égard nous avons
été reçus par le président par les
personnes qui sont chargées de la
valorisation de la recherche et puis à
l'instant nous sortons d'une réunion
absolument passionnante avec une
douzaine de start peur et donc nous
essayons de
sondés tous ces jeunes gens ou
ccc professionnels de l'innovation sur
les freins en fait qu'ils rencontrent ou
qu'ils ont pu rencontrer pour
transformer leurs innovations en projet
industriel
la france a deux forces alain côté une
très belle recherche qui peut aussi une
formation de qualité que ce soit des
ingénieurs des scientifiques des élèves
d'écoles de commerce et donc dans un
domaine de révolution technologique
aujourd'hui une très grande partie de
nos plans économiques ce sont des
nouvelles technologies eh bien nous
avons des start up j'ajouterai également
que le gouvernement même l'ensemble
assez françaises french tech de france
digital et bien à créer un écosystème
autour de ces nouvelles technologies qui
met ensemble en tout cas qui créent les
connexions entre les différents acteurs
et ses connexions à bien à créer mais
bien des dizaines des centaines de start
up dans les domaines vitaux c'est ça en
fait un des grands actifs on a vu
maintenant plus de 25 licorne qui est un
premier étape maintenant allons au delà
des 25 et développant des très très
grande entreprise qui vont justement
alimenter tous les marchés mondiaux
[Musique]
ont su réunir sur un même site un
certain nombre de structures qui
permettent à côté de la formation de la
recherche et de l'innovation d'avoir un
continuum qui permet donc à un certain
nombre d'ingénieurs un certain nombre de
docteurs un certain nombre de porteurs
de start-up peur d'avoir un contexte et
un écosystème qui favorise j'irai tout
tout leur développement
[Musique]